Hey guys, how's it going? It's Justine, and I am so excited because I absolutely love October, and guess what it is?
It's October. I love Halloween it's one of my favorite things ever and I love making Halloween treats
I did a whole week long of Halloween treats once, and I'm not doing that again cuz that was a lot of work
And that's something that I don't like. But what I do like, are treats. So we're gonna make something really fun today
These are little ghost ice cream cone cupcake things
So what we're gonna need are some ice cream cones and make sure you get the ones with like the flat bottoms because I've made
a really big mistake when I first bought these. They had the pointed tips, and guess what you can't do? You can't stand up the
Ice cream cones, and that's not gonna work for what we need to make today. Next we need to make a cake
Let me make sure this isn't expired
January 2018
We're in business. So today we're gonna be making this cake in a blender
I've got a lot of requests to bring the blender back, so guess what? It's back. If you're new here
And you're wondering why is this girl making a cake in a blender?
Then obviously you're new here. Welcome to the family. I appreciate it
So what we're gonna do
I'd like to give you guys a tip: when making things that you're not supposed to make it a blender always, put the liquids in
first. Those liquids include 1/4 cup of water
Did I say 1/4 cup? It's supposed to be 1 and 1/4 cup. Yep, okay.
In you go.
3 eggs
Two. Noo, there's a shell. Oh god. I gotta dive in here. I'm gonna unplug this because
I've seen way too many horror movies. Okay, well we're gonna leave that in there
And here we go we're making a cake in a blender.
That scared me so bad. I was not ready
I need a spatula!
The problem of making cakes in the blender is they do sometimes get stuck to the side here
So you just gotta get in there real good, give it a little scrape.
We're gonna be making cupcakes inside of ice cream cones
and it's pretty much the coolest thing ever. Here's our mixture.
So get yourself a cupcake tin like this one open up your
Ice cream cones. And you just put them in here like little cupcakes
Oops so spooky. So now we're going to be pouring in our mixture
That's why I decided to use the blender because this is great because you can just pour in the mixture
Cupcake batter. Don't fill it up too high because it will overflow. Yeah, I'd say like maybe like 3/4
There's a little line here, so I'm just kind of filling it up to that. So you're gonna wanna pre-heat your oven to
350 or something about that around there 375
(Alexa) 15 minutes starting now
Yes
Oh boy, do your job. Our ice cream cone cupcakes are in the oven and now we're going to be prepping our icing
I'm gonna be using Rosanna's little icing piping bags. I'm so excited this is the first time I'm gonna be using them
This is why I use knives. These scissors are worthless
So I wanted kind of a bigger tip because I want it to look kind of like soft-serve icing ice cream icing icing I'm
Using icing I'm making ice cream. This is super fluffy. Holy crap. Yeah get in there
This is so cute cause Ro has these little hearts on here
And they're actually
functional hearts
because you're not supposed to fill it past that.
I also thought I would be nice to do a little orange icing so for that we're
gonna add a little
That's a lot. We'll add some more might as well. A little bit of
food coloring to that one, and then I'll just mix it up
I definitely don't recommend doing this because I've done it before and it made a really big mess, but you know what?
Wowie!
That is very orange
OH MY GOD!
Alexa, shut up!
Like I just want to cry
Alexa
cancel. It's all over my phone like it's all over my phone. Oh my god.
Oh my god, it's all over my body!
I'm just like I'm not sure what to do. Like when the kids say "Oh I'm shook" like I'm legit shook.
(Off camera) It's all over everywhere.
It's everywhere, wowie
Okay, well uh, I guess I could take my
cupcakes out of the oven and, um, I'm gonna clean up a little
Hey you can't do I don't have much left. Ohhhh shoot.
This was supposed to be the easiest video, this is this is unfortunate
Oh my god
I'm getting very
very upset
No Clorox wipe my body it's fine
cool looking great
Mmm I'm a beautiful girl. Now I see why Rachael Ray doesn't wanna have me back on her show
Sorry girl!
Why even give a crap now. Oh no, it's coming out
Wow oh god, it's still com- oh no. Get out, get back in there
I think they're fairly cooled off. So now all we have to do is decorate. I mean, that's should be the easy part, right?
(Barking in background)
I'm only gonna have enough to make, like, one
Aw man this is gonna run all over the place.
If you're watching this video to, like, get an actual inspiration for Halloween treats
Does that look like a ghost? (Off camera)Yeah, looks like Jabba ghost. Oh, I'll put a little
ooooh I'm so spooky ooooh
It looks like Madde! Do not fall over
Spooky spooky orange. This is really great icing like I really like it a lot. Oh no, it's dripping off the side
It's melting like actual ice cream
Spooky eyeball number two oh my gosh. I'm squeezing this so hard
I wanna make him have a smile
Don't ever say I didn't try cuz obviously I did
wee!
These looks super cute. Mildly impressed, but not really that impressed cuz it's actually not that good.
That's a lot of icing
I mean like an entire canister for like four
Halloween sprinkles that I got at the craft store, I'm gonna do this over the trashcan because I am very sanitary
Oh, my gosh. These purple sprinkles are incredible. Whoops that's a lot
Good thing I don't have a bake shop because the health inspector would be here right now knocking on my door.
What are you doing?
And then I'm gonna say I don't know, what are you doing?
This one is a little bit, it doesn't even matter
This is a little crooked. I'm gonna put some of these on here. These are some super spooky sprinks
What is that?
I tried
Like if you even say that I didn't try I really did. Oh my god
It just looks like ants that's ugly don't do that
These have little purple ones in them too! I'm literally decorating cupcakes over a trash can
(Off camera) Thats so gross.
Yeah, normally I like to try my treats, but... To be fair, this is a brand new trash bag
I didn't have enough icing for these two, so I could just scoop this up off the floor off this. There we go
Mmmmm
I'll just add some icing here
I'm so sad. I thought these were gonna be so cute. They look garbage
Well guys, uh, that's it unfortunately, that's all I have for you.
I do think that some of these actually look kind of nice like this one looks kind of good
This one looks okay, if you like look at it from a certain angle
The ghosts definitely did not turn out the way that I thought, like I just gave up on those. Like, look at this
Alright well, thanks for watching. Happy almost Halloween!
Look for some more Halloween themed cooking videos in the coming weeks, and hopefully
or depending upon what type of videos you like maybe there will be more messes
I'm not sure. Yeah, that's all I have to say. Okay, Bye. Oh God
Wow. Wowie. It was a solid effort though, I will get myself an A for effort